we all know that Napoleon's invasion of
the Russian Empire ended how shall we
say poorly but one of the big questions
is what was he hoping to achieve and
were these goals realistic so a bit of
context when Napoleon had risen to power
in the year eight or 1799 is it normally
known Europe looked like this by 1812 on
the eve of Napoleon's famed invasion of
Russia it looked like this Napoleon had
managed to defeat the Prussian Russians
and Austrians before this and after
rearranging their territories had
demanded that they take part in what's
called the Continental System the
Continental System was basically the
don't trade with Britain club and this
lack of trade was quite damaging to
Russia as such in 1810 the Russians
simply opted to ignore Napoleon's demand
and trade anyway which the French
Emperor did not like one bit now this
wasn't the only problem that plagued
Franco Russian relations
the first was ideological Russia
represented everything that the French
Emperor despised it wanted a
meritocratic Europe in which certain
rights were enshrined in certain values
were seen as being simply universal and
Russia did not embody these ideas the
second issue was Poland in 1807 Napoleon
had defeated the fourth coalition and as
a result took this territory from
Prussia and gave it to the brand-new
Duchy of Warsaw in 1809 Austria tried to
defeat Napoleon and just like everyone
else they failed and so was punishment
for even trying in the first place they
lost this territory to the new polish
state so how does this concern Russia
well the last independent polish state
was the Polish Lithuanian Commonwealth
and that had been partitioned by Austria
Prussia and Russia this meant that a
large polish minority lived within
Russia meaning that if there was a
conflict between itself and Poland or
its patron France they would likely be
an uprising furthermore the close
friendship between the Duchy of Warsaw
in France meant the Poland could be used
as a launching point for an invasion
into Russia as such the Russians could
not tolerate an independent Poland
unless it accepted the Russian Emperor
as its king the poles in Napoleon said
no and so things got a little bit tense
so by 1812 the French Empire was deeply
bogged down by Spanish and Portuguese
resistance in the Peninsular war this
was becoming costly in terms of money
and lives and so as a result Napoleon
needed a win and what better way to do
so than to have a quick and easy victory
by invading Russia
Napoleon knew that he couldn't continue
to fight the costly Peninsular war and
invade Russia without Prussia and
Austria on side as such Napoleon
pressured them to commit small forces to
the invasion which they agreed to the
idea being that they would make an enemy
of Russia and so wouldn't be able to
against Napoleon so as we all know
Napoleon's invasion of Russia was a
complete failure and so surely he must
have been able to predict some of the
issues he faced right well know Napoleon
was convinced of his own genius and
considered the Russians to be an
inferior people who would be unable to
withstand his armies for very long as we
all know this invasion went terribly for
France and Napoleon stays in power were
soon numbered so in summary Napoleon
invaded Russia for many reasons to
enforce the Continental System which in
theory would starve Britain of money and
resources to destroy Russia is a
potential future enemy so that France
could focus entirely on the Spanish
Portuguese in the British and to
strengthen his grip over Eastern and
Central Europe as well as the new polish
state to enforce Napoleonic ideals there
however the most obvious reason he
invaded was simple he thought he was
going to win I hope you enjoyed this
episode and thank you for watching with
extra thanks to my patrons that you see
on screen now and a special thanks to
James Bissonnette David archaeologist
Zarqa flash Party Boyko Rob Waterhouse
Yashar Enderman Chris wicker Myles
Bailey Brent guard Michael Reynolds
Gustav Swann tun Rick Onion duck Maggie
pax Kowski Winston k-word phacelia
Ravidas
Anthony Beckett Adam Harvey Ike Skye
Chappelle and the amusement park Ives